on the mound tonight for the padres zach
davies has had a great season
absolutely 27 year old going for number
eight making his tenth start faces off
against these dodgers for the first time
here at petco park second time this
season for the eighth time of his career
vets goes to second and there's one out
justin turner makes his return from the
injured list
turner swings in a fly ball to right
field
toward the corner he's going to drop in
front of myers for a base hit
pence will come around to score an rbi
single to right
off the bat of justin turner welcome
back justin turner and the dodgers take
a one-to-nothing lead
25-year-old making a sixth start
remember last time he pitched against
the pod race he did well
four two thirds he struck out eight he's
got the fourth seam of the split as a
secondary picture slider and a curve
ball four pitch mix
he's having a good season era one five
seven opponents only hitting
178 off tony gosselin that tren grisham
guy
that troublemaker then tatis and then
machado
down one run on the ground into that
shift and it's taylor and short right
throws out grisham for the first out
here in the bottom of the first inning
gonzalon coming in with a 1.57 earned
run average he's retired the first five
padres in a row look out watch your face
up and in and myers almost ducked into
that ball wow
will myers stumbling back helmet going
flying
along with the bat he can buckle up his
seat belt
the 2-2 will with a high-fly ball pretty
well hit
into right field i thought he got a lot
of that but not all of it will be off
the wall
off the track and off the wall throw to
second base head first slide
say first padre base runner first
primary hit
there's a two-out double by meyers here
the tying run is in scoring position
the dodgers have first and third two out
and cody bellinger coming up
swings and lines up base hit into center
field so bellinger delivered in the
score is
turner and there's two out at rbi single
for cody bellinger dodgers two to
nothing
well sometimes it just one base hit will
get you rolling and hopefully that was
the one for bellinger
profar is now at third with one out and
trent grisham
who bounced to second base in his first
at-bat stepping in
he pulls it up the first base side
godzilla can't get it seeger charges he
won't have a play
bunt base hit and a run andre's making
it 2-1 here in the third inning
as they manufacture themselves their
first run of the night grisham pulling
it with him dragging it
up the first base side he got it past
the pitcher once you do that you got a
shot
and in the shift it was seeger coming on
to try and bare-handed he didn't have a
play profile scores easily
two to one edwin learned the game from
his dad who was quite the player himself
edwin senior played pro ball in puerto
rico that's the egg deep down the line
to white making edwin senior proud home
run for edwin rios sprinting the dodgers
ahead 3-1
snapping a slump rios has really been
struggling in september
but he turned on that ball and left no
doubt tamuki bets if they go to the top
of the order here
that's a line one caught a third by
machado up into the air to make the
ground
amazing first step great reaction
there's a gold glover working for you
that ball is actually hooking
boy hits the palm of his glove down into
the webbing great concentration man he's
done that many many times before
wow will smith one for two stepping in
with two out
high fly ball center field that is a
slide that is grisham
that's a dive and that's a catch in
center field smith
gets burned and the padres give up just
the one run and absolutely could have
been
much worse yeah davey's night is
finished
hill who was acquired from kansas city
right before the start of the season
grounded up the middle tatis to his left
has it from the grass behind second one
pounds throw is in time
what a play fernando tatis jr nicely
done by moreland at first to handle the
big bounce but
tease made that look far easier than it
was one away
godzilla's retired seven padres in a row
that's two outs in the seventh and jake
cronenworth's coming up
brownson went to rio's front worth
retired another great inning for
gonzalon
who is having a spectacular night a run
in four hits is all he's given up
through seven
here's caleb ferguson for the eighth
inning swung on and missed strike three
ferguson just heard it just something's
wrong
as he released the pitch you can see his
face grimace
and he's already walking off the field
he's done so ferguson
and trying to get a couple of k's to
start this bottom of the eighth now
grisham
he swings and rounds it right to
bellinger backhanded stab
jobs to the bag but the ending is open
the run so hits though errors nobody
left will go to the ninth
this is the bounty ball left side tati
backhand the very edge of the
third cut out one bounce throw in time
what a gun sorry second time he's done
that in the last few innings he got
kiki hernandez and a seventh on a very
similar play very similar throw
almost like the old astro turf days
giving the big hop to the first baseman
nine career lone saves for jason versus
san diego in his career so the time run
is in scoring position the winning run
is aboard and the hitter is will myers
he struck him out with the slider base
is loaded two gone and jake cronin worth
comes up
he struck him out kenley janssen
eeks his way out of this and the dodgers
have tied the series in a game of peace